interesting [ __ ]
this show is presented by on it
but days are back the church of what's
happening now is proud to introduce you
to hellotushy.com that's right
hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt clean with water
he knows what i'm talking about
go to hellotushy.com slash church right
now to get 10 off of your order hello
hellotissue.com
church
the show is also brought to you by
texture the texture app lets you tap
into the world's most popular magazines
anytime anywhere using your smartphone
or tablet and the best part is texture
is offering our listeners a free trial
right now when you go to texture.com
joey that's texter.com
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
hello john for you [ __ ] tonight
you're like who the [ __ ] is elton john
joe
one of the greats
one of the greats
he's just too busy jumping up and down
listening to bad music that's what the
[ __ ] problem is
church of what's happening now
wednesday november 30th it's over
[ __ ]
but the south space
jets
[Music]
kick that mute lee
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
and the jets
[Music]
these [ __ ] don't know about
elton john great groups oh what are you
gonna do with the young people but then
struck them joey i try and like i said
to you every time i hail in john i go
jesus christ how do i put something
together to show the world elton john
like
it was like six years that he just ruled
with an eye in hand when i was growing
up absolutely six or seven years three
hours through the whole 70s he was he
was just ripping it up because i
remember his last song that i really
liked was i'm still standing yeah who
was that that was like 83 yeah 83. he
wore the hat in that one yeah now he was
trying to lose his head and he didn't
get to pay yet the road game didn't work
didn't take no it didn't take sure to
what's happening now greg proops
lee siyat what's going on lee i'm doing
uh i'm doing good chocolate's [ __ ]
good uh you you say things to me in the
morning and i don't think you realize
that it sends me into like a like a
mental downward spiral throughout the
day
because like
you said something and you were laughing
we were i'm having an issue with
something and you said there's always a
fire to put out and like you say these
things and you just hang up and you
leave me to like
go into like these spirals because it's
you always talk about like when you
first were finding a job
how like you didn't think you could do
it for 40 years or whatever
that like that freaked me out to i'm
like
it's never gonna get there's never gonna
be an easy down like calm
no fires to put out at all scenario and
like i i kind of like i almost called
you i was like i can't do the podcast
today i was like i was still in like i
was in bed like kind of you just still
stole someone last night it was a way i
didn't get stoned last night actually
last night i got stalled
and i watched two documentaries that
were on hbo about cuba okay nice and the
first one was
just talking about the economics in cuba
and these people saying listen
all this [ __ ] that you're saying is
great
but where's the paper
nobody we have no expectations
we have no like future
we do the same [ __ ]
every day
with no
light at the end of the tunnel that's
the word then what yeah no light at the
end of the [ __ ] puzzle you know
and that's how i felt at times when i
was
22 23
when you realized okay so i went to high
school i did what they told me i went to
college
i made a little pit stop in prison
now what now what so what you're telling
me is whatever job i choose at 27 years
old i'm doing this until i'm 65 to get a
[ __ ] watch right
that's that [ __ ] threw me
into a four day like then whatever i'm
gonna do i better [ __ ] be in love
with yeah i better not do it for the
money that was a complete different
lesson now
now it's not even about the money i got
to do something that i [ __ ] like
you know i liked what i was doing i
liked what i was trying to be right but
taking a train with a brown bag every
day and you got to pay for dry cleaning
that's not my bad
that's never been my bag a little brown
bag
and at the end of the week you got to
pay an extra 90 for dry cleaning and and
[ __ ] take a train every morning and
this is it
this is it till those two weeks you get
off every year this is it
i couldn't handle that
that's why i said [ __ ] it i might as
well do this [ __ ] was that when you
started being a stand-up when you were
27
no i got on stage the first time
yeah i got on stage when i was 27.
i was i knew their marriage wasn't
working i was failing it
i just was wasn't failing at life like i
had a job
and i was making good money but that was
it
that was it the crushing weight i was 20
years old 27 years old i had
i finally gave up and went to work for
my in-laws on the roof
after six months i couldn't see me just
roofing yeah so i played the estimating
game and i just wrote to the companies
and they had estimating clinics
so i would fly myself or
and i learned how to estimate uh-huh you
know i said i'm not going to [ __ ] be
40 on these roofs
which stories i mean one time we did 90
yards and the tower was hot that ain't
that ain't me yeah it's like when you
get locked up you meet people and they
brag to you about their prison resume
yeah
and people go you oh you got to get
arrested in kansas so you got to get
arrested in connecticut to jail there
the guy will go you know what i got a
sister in connecticut that's not a bad
idea
like
it's like they they're proud of their
resume it's the same thing with these
roofers which was a great i loved it i i
was in great shape you're getting
vitamin d i was in colorado you know
it's it's not humid that was great
but the cold hard reality at 27 years
old is this is what i'm [ __ ] doing
the rest of my life
so i tried the estimating and i was
pretty good at that and i was hustling
on the weekends uh i was a commercial
estimator which was buildings
but on the weekends i would go into
these little neighborhoods and hail
damage and i'd work them to death
and i'd get a house on saturday in the
house on sunday and again
i'm like okay so the bank account is
straight this is straight
but
there hasn't been a day off in 20
[ __ ] days
that's not life either
so
i didn't i got into this not really
because of economic relief
i got into this knowing i was going to
be broke i got into this
because at least i wanted to like what i
did
there was nothing i liked let's face it
you know i i love cooking i don't like
[ __ ] cooking i like cooking a
hamburger for me you know i'm saying
salt and pepper
a bun ketchup you cut up an onion that's
it i'm good
but if you think i want to cook a
thousand [ __ ] hamburgers chef [ __ ]
you chef
you know there's nothing i like right
construction was great for three weeks
yeah i was surprised you said six months
i'm like i don't think i can handle it
but i'm not a i can't i'm not every job
i had was just a terrible uh
what the jobs did you have that you
[ __ ] went in there and go what the
[ __ ] is mine
you know i was a busboy and a paper boy
and a waiter and a dishwasher all those
you know jobs 70s entry level you're 16
15 that's what you get
uh no one's going to make you a
bookkeeper or anything and
am i striving for excellence was not
exactly at the forefront of my mind and
then i delivered pizza for a while for a
guy who
uh sold uh meth in uh in burlingame and
he he was a ex-con
jarhead
and um his mother worked there did i
tell you this one last time i don't
think so birmingham vermont burlingame
california on the peninsula okay i'm
from san carlos which is a tiny white
little place 30 miles south of san
francisco and um burlingame is about
halfway up uh toward the city and
see where i'm from san francisco you're
from new york in
the west coast the city of san francisco
and in new york people go you mean new
york and i'm like no i mean the city my
other city yeah yeah that's how that's
how parochial we are we think there's
one city
uh
and anyways uh yeah so i i i looked at
an ad in a paper
you remember when you looked at the wan
ads and it said driver wanted must have
car w slash ins
uh apply pizza man chicken delight
burlingame and so uh i went down
and he was there a little goatee
a complexion like someone
his face had been a flame and someone
put it out with a bicycle chain you know
like how old were you at this time in
1819 like just skating right no [ __ ]
direction i'd been an actor i'd done a
little comedy i did stuff in high school
and i was going to junior college but
you know
i didn't know what i think at that point
i wanted to be a dj which was a career
in 1979 or whatever
and uh
so nothing was going on i had long hair
i had a mickey mouse shirt i remember
you know giant elton john glasses and
so i walk into the place and he goes uh
you get poops what's your name troops
proofs what you got a car yeah all right
come back at four
that was it right that was the whole
interview uh it's a doll it's a buck a
run that was a big deal right and all
that and you get all the tips so i came
back and uh they had a map on the wall
this is the old days of the whole area
where the pizza deliveries took place
and there were pins in it which i
thought was hilarious like churchill you
know it's like the war room like a
strategic pizza strike on millbrae
avenue or whatever
and um
i did a bunch of deliveries the first
night driving around i had a chevy vega
with a cassette duck i love this [ __ ]
remember the chevy vegas it's a
hatchback because that's you can keep
the doors in the bag you put the pizzas
in the back and they give you a little
crappy styrofoam oven to put them in and
i listen to ksol or or kdia which are
the sole stations uh and uh smoke cools
and rode around some people ordered the
same thing every night like there was a
lady and you had to stop and get her paw
malls and milk and [ __ ]
and then uh you go to uh
so i finished the first night and uh i
get back and he goes hey you did pretty
good you made like 30
pizza runs or whatever and he goes uh
you smoke weed and i'm like yeah
and he goes well because i deal with so
of course the money i've made the first
night
we yeah and uh then
he of course reveals eventually within a
day or two that he is a
a speed dealer of course in those days
we called it crank
we didn't call it meth
and uh
so i worked for him for a few months and
i didn't deliver meth for him but i
would sometimes have to go to deliver
pizzas to his dealer's house and those
were always free right and sometimes the
dealer would come in and he drove a
black trans am with a giant eagle on the
front right and he had the waisted
girlfriend with the bell bottoms and the
short rabbit for a jacket and he wore a
leather vest and a civil war had a no
shirt right and an iron cross
and uh
yeah
real real
so you come in in the afternoon uh and i
don't know if you've ever you know
you'd hear him upstairs uh
you'd hear
right when i'd walk in
you know ding ding the door and he'd go
props right cause he could hear the door
open
fold some [ __ ] boxes that was the
worst job right when you were doing
nothing when you were waiting to make a
delivery you had to full pizza boxes
and um
then finally the delivery started above
you know 4 35 but you got to get there
at four okay somebody ordered a [ __ ]
pizza for uh
so at the end of the night
there was these two little kids who who
uh put the is this getting long and
boring no no no no these two little
kids [ __ ]
this is a job when you're a teenager
right like uh
people said to me you know you're thrown
into the world and expected to like be
an adult i had a car i had to pay
insurance i was living at home my dad
said get the [ __ ] out and get a job so i
took the first [ __ ] thing that i saw
on the first thing i got so anyway these
two little kids would come in and
they're about eight and ten and um they
would ride up in their stingrays and
chuck them in the alley and they'd come
in and they'd put the chicken in milk
and they'd have to bread it and
everything
lonnie cut it right like there was a
a band saw that cut chicken chicken came
in a giant crate like a chinese
restaurant right with the chickens on
ice and then uh and he would slice them
with a saw which was a murder right and
he was janked on
speed all the time so his mood his mood
varied between
hitler and like satan on a bad weekend
like you know he he was very rarely
jovial he was grumpy
and they would break the chicken and he
paid them and weed they were little kids
right they took weed for their face so
after hours
we go in the back room the chicken room
and i've said i've described it before
is it was so much like a horror show
that it should have been in black and
white right like
there's chickens in a thing and there's
a garbage can full of chickens and you
know old pizzas and
there was two records he owned uh rod
stewart's night on the town and
uh james brown's greatest hits on some
obscure you know bootleg and we would
put those on and then we'd all smoke
weed and dance around his sister worked
there his mother
her sister's jacked up boyfriend the two
little kids
and i'm i'm still freaked out about the
two eighteen eight and ten-year-olds who
were butchering the what were they they
were butchering the chickens yeah they
they they didn't have to run the saw
mind you they just had to put it in the
milk and let it soak and then put it in
the breading and then take it out and
put it in the fridge
and uh that was their job and and i
don't know that they received money or
that they convinced their parents maybe
they were bringing home 10 bucks or
whatever but they were definitely
getting
bags of weed so they were the coolest
kids i'm sure at their high school or
you know grade school in the fifth grade
class right in fifth grade in burlingame
and uh we would dance to james brown and
[ __ ] and then uh he's handing me a joint
lonnie and uh bobby uh the the sister's
boyfriend comes up and goes did uh he
handed you a joint and i'm like yeah and
he goes
don't hit on his man because he smokes
angel dust right like
he he'd taken so much speed that he
couldn't really get high like like we
would just smoke a joint you know what i
mean we still could join we get high and
then we're like we're high right he had
to go the extra mile to smoke
pcp right horse tranquilizer as it was
yeah that was always poppy and uh
biscuits so i i was like oh four four
you know four warned is four armed right
like thank you for telling me that he's
smoking [ __ ] angel dust cause i gotta
get back in my car and go to my
uh
he didn't tell you your nine just
handled you uh-huh that seemed a little
bit dude he had been in the joint he had
a marine tattoo um he had other crudely
etched tattoos that i assume were done
by a gentleman he knew inside
and uh he was uh
you know the real and his father
sometimes was there his mother
sat in a wheelchair
and she rolled up and down the counter
and there was the spike right remember
those you'd write that order out and you
put it
on the spike right and they were the
most dangerous thing in the world like
they were it was it was literally
yes it was they still have them i always
i'm surprised no one ever puts their
hand through it right that's the thing
no one ever puts a [ __ ] hand through
it
because
so they put the thing on and she had a
phone with the cushy you know the 70s
the giant cushion that you could put
your
head on
and
one of those you know 1970s with six
lines on it
and i said to her what's are you okay
tina you know like do you you know do
you need help and she's like oh i don't
need the wheelchair i just don't like
walking around
oh my god
so she took orders and would roll up and
down the counter were they greek or were
they white trash were they
yeah hysterical i think they might have
been italian the sister had that
fantastic haircut where there's the
brown stripe there and the bleach blonde
hair
and the the 70s jeans with the
embroidery you know
oh yeah it was pretty i lasted there i
don't think i don't maybe six months you
know
we would go to concerts in san francisco
like we talked about last time you going
to new york we went in and saw blondie i
remember
uh
um
richie blackmore's rainbow
um this sounds like dinosaurs now but
this is who we would go see they would
have to watch it so i go up with my
buddy jay and we were going to the and
i've stopped me if i told you this part
we're going what year is this
70s 78 78 it was on fire yeah yeah they
were huge uh we're going to see it and
so we park it that fillmore in san
francisco isn't it used to be in a
really bad neighborhood now there are
very few really bad neighborhoods in san
francisco but there's still enough uh
and uh it was falling apart every time i
went there part of the ceiling would
follow me i remember having a piece of
wood from the floor it had a beautiful
hardwood floor it was an old venue you
know it's like from the 20s or something
and um the grateful dead did that show
there with uh the blues brothers in like
78 they did new year's and they all were
on you know
painted blue and whatnot anyway uh
uh
we're trying to park and my friend goes
get out of the car and try and put in a
small space there's nowhere to fall
apart there's no parking lot or nothing
and i'm high and drunk we've been
drinking tequila and snorting [ __ ]
meth and you know i'm
shit-faced
and i'm standing in the middle of the
street like an idiot on steiner and a
black uh link continental with like
comes down the street and i go [ __ ] you
you know i'm a teenager right and the
[ __ ]
pull back right the windows go down
and there's these two
400 pound somalian dudes right and their
eyes are [ __ ] glazed burning red
volcanoes of centroids of murder
and uh well my joke is you they had
weaponry hanging from the filials right
like there was a musket and a sword you
know but they had one of those little
steering wheels you remember those that
are chains right that's this big this is
in a black catwalk right and
the window goes down and the guy goes is
there a problem
and i'm i'm like [ __ ] myself right
so i go no no no there's no problem
my friend's on the other side of the
street yeah everything's cool and uh
they're like because if there's a
problem
you know
we'll
we'll we'll deal with that right now
and i'm like absolutely gentlemen this
is the night of bonami between friends
and
i was celebrating life and all of its
single-digit glory you know i danced i
danced and then they went okay because
if there's a problem and i'm like no
there's no problem finally
[ __ ] car takes off just then my
friend gets out of the car and goes
what's the matter with you i'm sitting
on the sidewalk now like with my head in
my hands my heart's racing
i'm almost in tears because i thought
they're gonna shoot me right like
just for being a [ __ ]
douchebag who went like this
and he's like what happened and i'm like
that guys came along
you know
i'm just a little [ __ ]
idiot white kid from the suburbs and uh
so
there was some fun
you ran into it now let me ask you this
what
it was crank but speed was the [ __ ] in
capsules
yeah speed was either in a black capsule
right black people that's what i was
there were the whites which we also
called crosstalk
and yes right yes
and they had a cross across them like
that
theoretically you could break them into
four i suppose but no one ever did when
you worked in restaurant business the
one thing you were guaranteed was that
everybody took speed this is in the 70s
right not crank but that was because i
worked for a gangster who [ __ ] sold
crank for another guy but
uh
because crank makes you break out and
then if you do it for a bunch of as you
know uh it's an epidemic of this country
but if you do it for several days you
don't you're not light-hearted you're
depressed right i mean the best time of
course is the first giant line of it
when your head explodes and your eyes
you know you feel like you're crying
ammonia you know
uh
but it's not like a fun-loving it's
basically so you can drink
i think really or maybe it's not maybe
that's the drink
i don't know how i got
cross-tops we would eat to work on not
just to get high but to work everybody
used to always uh
[ __ ] talk about pills and [ __ ] i
never wanted to see those
then when i was about 16 i went out one
night and i bought a gram of speed
i didn't do it that night i did it the
next day in the morning right and it
jacked me up right right i'm getting
everything done no no i went to school i
had half a day we drank
and it was just craziness and then i did
it again i saved a little bit of it i
did it again i think i threw that away
and that was my experience so is it
adderall or no no no you have to snort
it like code
speed is made by bikers in uh right i
bought it from bikers
it's usually in those days it was
yellowy and lumpy it was lumpy it wasn't
like a pure white crystalline television
it didn't fall down in beautiful flakes
it was a a messy affair yeah it wasn't
known it tasted shitty and it made the
back of your throat feel like
the the taste is unforgettable it's
horrible uh
no this wasn't adderall we didn't like i
said the black beauties were really
strong method of black beauty these were
like dexa drinks or whatever [ __ ]
kill you
and then i got into those but then my
buddy's like
you're eating them
yeah pop them open and snort it right so
the last experience i had those was
those things and i was selling them i
was getting them in pennsylvania and
bringing them back to north america and
selling them and they got to the point i
would just pop them and pop them in my
nose jesus [ __ ] christ and what what
is the point because i know to stay up
for two [ __ ] days and talk
endlessly you could do any other drug on
top of it because it was so strong and
the speed jacked you so hard that you
could drink all you wanted smoke dope
all you wanted take acid whatever and
just be
cranked out and if you did not sleep
well
fit full uh but you could you could do a
lot of things you could you went like
the wind
students are doing the study i didn't my
friends were doing the losing weight to
study wrestlers getting to lose weight
and then i did it to get high and to
work the first thing i ever snorted
that was very popular was what you said
he was was thc crystal
that was what they sold it at but
it was guerrilla treasure
yeah it was dust
and that tasted sensational
and i had done it all summer long
i would do it on the weekends with a
friend of mine who i still talked to
and
i got a lung infection from paraquad and
they sprayed the pot yeah i'll never
forget that they came into the room they
go tomorrow you're getting scheduled for
uh surgery it's minus surgery
what we're going to basically do is
put you out and then get a tube and go
into your lung and scrape your lung and
see what's in there and then we'll
analyze and get back to you i'm like my
mom's gonna [ __ ] find that
i did that thc i might as well tell her
before she finds out yeah and i finally
said [ __ ] that i ain't committing the
dick
let her come in here and shake me down i
play it off like maybe i ate weed or
something yeah and they never said
nothing about it but i did it
i did that for about six months i liked
the taste of it
then i did the blow and then i did that
[ __ ]
that speed stuff
i didn't really like that stuff and over
the years i've done it like if i'm out
and somebody uh you're at a club in like
[ __ ]
portland or something not even portland
last time i did it was in
the uh
boise idaho the boys
to do it yeah i went to the bar
and at the bar two people offered me
powder and i took one and
when i went to the bathroom i realized
wait a second this ain't blow yeah
this is [ __ ] i said you can tell
instantly instantly
and once i did it they kicked the mule
and i gave the package back and i go wow
how bad can one bump dude right oh my
god and boise did you work that room no
boys i'm into boise boise had a pretty
cool funny bone
but the hotel was very rustic it was
from 1920 right and people like to stay
there i don't like those hotels all
right give me your [ __ ] motel sex all
right those hotels from the 1800s that
george michael george washington it's
michael whatever his [ __ ] name is
that's not for me i don't give a [ __ ]
george michael slept here lee
you uh obviously he's been in those
rooms in vegas when you do a vegas room
they give you a suite yeah and you bring
lee upstairs and we we we eat stars and
we watch tv and he's like this is the
biggest room i've ever seen in my life
listen to me
the room they put you out in boise idaho
made those vegas rooms
look like dick
it was so big i get lost
was it like a house it was four rooms to
a floor i'm telling you this is when
hotels were hotels they read whatever
rejuvenated it and put beat bars on it
but it creaked right can you imagine
doing a line of [ __ ] method right in
the room that creaks every time the wind
blew the whole [ __ ]
kicker and i would have to get up i
couldn't jerk off in the shower it was
six showers in the [ __ ] room
yeah you gotta see this dining room
three showers four toilets you got a
super villain meeting and it was uh i
did the math i went upstairs i'll be up
till three right two i was up for two
[ __ ] days yeah
they weren't goofing around i stayed up
all night friday right all night did the
show the next night
oh i mean all night when you're in bed
going i'm going to fall asleep and i'll
say you're like no you're not yeah and
they would just come back and hit you
and if you smoked a joint it would come
back and smack you around i was like
i'll never do that [ __ ] again
how how was your comedy show horrific
horrific and that was
96 summer of 96 and the headliner was
chris titus
and i know chris and then i moved to la
years later and i go on a creative
international tour
this was when creative was created they
still had carrot top right and they
would put you in all those five
one-nighters that paid it wasn't a
triple tour triple paid 75 and one and a
quarter right these guys paid 175 and
250 right which you can make a [ __ ]
living on you know a triple run so i
took a week
and at that time you know it was 99 98 i
was living in la you know i would go to
the comedy store pick up a package it
was just a part of life now i'm in
[ __ ]
bum [ __ ] uh
tennessee and that's okay for one night
then i go somewhere else and that's okay
for two nights by thursday i don't have
to tell you great proofs i needed
something i needed a quicker picker up
you know what i'm saying i need
something to put uncle joey back
together yeah
so friday night i'm in this town and i
got i got the 10 monkeys on my back
scratching
and finally i just went by the bathroom
and i just waited for the first person
to go
yeah and finally some guy went in there
with work boots and yeah ripped jeans it
smelled like a [ __ ] ape
and i heard him sniffing i caught him in
the hole and i go dog you got to give me
some of that he goes absolutely
i finished mine but you got to follow me
after the show
so the feature act i had a car i go come
on yeah follow this guy this one for 10
15 20 30 minutes yeah yeah he takes me
into this [ __ ] thing
he took me right to breaking bad yeah i
didn't know yeah i wish i could tell you
i knew what was going on right i got out
of the car goes what do you want
i go whatever get me a gram how much he
goes give me 25 hours i go
who the [ __ ] are you buying this coke
from yes it ain't coming yeah that ain't
because crank baby yeah
i'm like god damn it and at that point i
followed you all the way out here i
don't do crank but [ __ ] give it to me
anyway because i don't want to go home
empty-handed oh my god i did two bumps
that i threw the rest out that [ __ ] was
pure
you know yeah night train i never did it
again that was the last time you can
kill your sinuses too kill it just kill
them
because you don't you're not flushing
them out in those days you don't [ __ ]
you know
and you can get real sick i'm very happy
i knock on wood i never got hooked on i
got dear friends
that started [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
and next you know their son called me
and said dog they're in there four days
smoking they don't even come out to eat
don't even come out to eat
they buy a big chunk on friday and they
don't come out for the [ __ ] they just
go in the shower [ __ ] and come out this
is a kid that's 25 calling me and
telling me about his parents that are
both [ __ ] close to 50.
jesus christ
i like the only
experience i've ever had with uh with
that is like i thought truckers did it i
didn't know people actually did it for
like fun i thought it was like people
who were doing it to stay up just to
stay out a lot of people are but a lot
of people do it when i first started
triple runs i would eat those no doses
and drink mountains oh yeah i already
know those [ __ ] mine would blow but
nothing like when you do a line today oh
no nothing
lee and it plays with you
like you'll start going [ __ ] joey
lied to me he says
he said i was gonna be up all night
well he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying
you lay down and you're like
in bed and you're like what the [ __ ]
just happened and you're a jerk off nine
times nothing comes out blood comes out
ious come on and you're sitting there
like what the [ __ ] and it's two in the
afternoon
the house is creepy if you go out
something feels weird remember we're
talking about tweaking yeah i didn't
like i didn't like those no doses
because no no no like i would feel like
tired but i just couldn't fall asleep
it's a terrible feeling like it almost
hurts to be tired like you're so tired
it hurts like like what is it like on
the second day of being awake
i've only done that once
your mood does not improve no i can
remind you
your mood descends rapidly
and after a week or two of it it's not
yeah
i don't know you know
when i was a t i didn't really do it
after that you know other drugs but not
meth was the only really worked for the
guy who and you know and like i said
when you worked in restaurants but that
we didn't snort meth in restaurants we
took whites
or black i didn't do anything rest in
the restaurants i worked that in aspen
you snorted coke yeah oh and that's out
83 you snorted [ __ ] mountains yeah
those cooks were back there the one cook
was a dealer the bus boys were stealing
well that's the thing every restaurant
oh my god restaurants are the were all
you didn't have to go to youtube there
was dealers i went to colorado to get
away from it right here i am in new york
city in colorado the first month i'm
great i'm not itching for it it's not
around me i'm going to bars i'm meeting
people i'm mingling i'm not [ __ ]
depend i'm not even asking people for it
and then i moved to snowmass village and
uh
then somebody offered it to me you know
and then i would just do a little
package on friday nights i'd watch that
night flight yeah and do a little
package on usa and then bang one out at
six and go to bed nobody knew nothing
and then somebody says to me dog uh what
are you doing like i i shovel snow in
the daytime they go listen come up to
the tower it was john denver's
restaurant
come up there and be a dishwasher pays
you 50 bucks and we'll get your job on
tuesdays it's prime rib night if you
lift weights and stuff yeah
we'll give you prime rib shrimp
and it was
like it was a complete i thought like i
was i thought like i was the king of
coke in new york these guys had me beat
colorado blew my mind at a young age
like to what i thought my i thought i
was going to be around once a [ __ ]
white dude that shoveled snow and went
skiing yeah they threw me into snowmass
aspen which was completely
uh
completely out of my expectations i
didn't think there was gonna be cocaine
up there i thought it was gonna be a
little weed and you gotta fight for it
and i mean these guys
they were from the one guy was from san
francisco
and the one guy was from like
seattle or something
and these guys from the middle i walked
in there
every 20 minutes on the 20. oh yeah they
tap you on the shoulders they go in the
freezer
and you went in the freeze and there was
a line of coke you know two inches
i was 19.
by [ __ ] 11 30. i'd be out of my mind
and then they'd give me a pound of
shrimp they'd steal shrimp and go take
that on us who wants shrimp yeah yeah i
can't even [ __ ] shrimp you can't eat
a cracker how was that shrimp last night
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
only did it tuesdays but then it was
such a good time and you snorted so much
blow that i said give me more ships and
they started giving me like thursdays
and sundays these guys were [ __ ]
animals like
and it was like i was around people that
were they would be [ __ ] wrecked
by eleven because they'd be drinking i
didn't drink yeah they'd be [ __ ]
drinking behind the line after that we
clean up and we go back to one of their
houses and then i would pull [ __ ]
bags and shoot darts
i call these guys a [ __ ] hand yes i
mean i thought i hung out with animals
back then i gotta show them these
[ __ ] gorillas it's crazy how
i guess sheltered i was because the most
i ever saw was weed and i never i know
i've never in my life
ever had an experience with a dealer
so i i never i
it blows my mind here that there's so
many people dealing drugs like i can't
i'm gonna tell you one bet at least i
i'm gonna give this to greg proops
and anybody could steal this because it
doesn't matter we all have ten different
experiences
in your spare time you're an author
because i'm gonna do it
i'm going to write about my 10 favorite
drug dealers
of all time yeah that's a good idea
it's it's something that
you can it's going to go from here to
here
like from here and i'm not talking about
weed i had some pretty cool weed dealers
i'm talking about people when it gets
out there that they might they can have
a kilo of coke in their apartment a
couple [ __ ] grenades
and uh
and and microwave ovens for sale like
that type of combo like i've been to
those houses where you you know
microwave oven man what are you talking
about
yeah you need microwave i'm here to buy
six ounces of bloat what are you talking
i got microwaves i got leather jackets
you know i got barbiturates right and
you're like not like i have
when you were telling me that story
about that crazy guy up there i kept
thinking about this guy
one of my first drug dealers his name
was patty
and he worked for a tv station at the
time
he had like a good job but he was one of
the pioneers of kokum like i knew my
family was into it and i knew people at
the bar i'm talking about my first
experience that went on the outside
another [ __ ] dude
that always wore robe and slippers right
you know he always had a robot prince he
always had some he lived in a studio
apartment but he had the
you know circle couch this is this was
a studio 54
as can be he always had studio music on
it you know and a
really creepy guy whatever i dealt with
him for like two years
and then he moved on and i moved on i
forgot about it and about a year and a
half ago i'm on facebook
and who do i see
this [ __ ] guy and guess what
he hasn't stopped sun tanning
right now since those days yeah like he
was one of those guys i said no he's a
date listen don't come between eight and
nine because you know i suntan okay
right
you know he was one of those guys that
but i saw him i had some interesting
that's a very good idea for a book
the top 10 drug dealers in your [ __ ]
world out of how many do you think
roughly
35
40.
how do you think people get drugs lee
i'd really americans are watching drugs
i don't know i just i i imagine in like
every time there's like one guy who's
shady who is
like i know
like i guess in bigger cities but no i
don't know middle america is where
there's drugs
i'm sure yeah you know like meth and all
that is an oxy
uh but we didn't do those oxy wasn't a
drug we had quaaludes we had qualities
uh
terminals quaaludes reds i guess
something else there was something we
took in california we were more mushroom
weed we were more acid and we took acid
too there was all those there was always
us there was no
mushrooms when i was growing up right i
left jersey in 83 i never had a [ __ ]
mushroom okay i had heard people
speaking about him my buddy went to asu
what was asu
and he called me he said dog get on a
[ __ ] plane these [ __ ] are
eating shrooms growing them and smoking
them
they're seeing they're going teepees and
they're sitting there for three days
they take their shoes off because i had
never seen that people think of their
shoes
from [ __ ] jersey keep your shoes on i
never forget i'm saying that to me
people take their shoes off my shoes oh
my god
and that's the i heard
we did the micro dot acid yeah the
little dot and we did paper and four way
yeah that was it uh a double barrel
sunshine on that [ __ ] came on paper
coke
heroin crank the pills
and that was it once i got to colorado
everything switched over from
coke everything switched over to
mushrooms in my world right which i
never liked because i got diarrhea right
four i was in everybody's having a good
time in the [ __ ] bathroom looking
around with fluid coming out of your ass
this ain't a trip this is a [ __ ]
nightmare i'm saying there's a hot chick
out there showing a [ __ ] right and i
mean [ __ ] in blood the thing about
mushrooms is they're difficult on your
digestive system they even make you feel
like you're going to throw up when you
first eat them sometimes this poor
bastard oh yeah he turns purple
okay
can you wash the [ __ ] off of him he
brings them to me you can't even that's
a lot of white mission that's part of
the mission what are you talking about
that's that's possible supposed to just
snarf them down or eat it on a piece of
pizza that's what we used to do in
college yeah yeah that would be like
there's no pizza here just hands to me
like these brownies chew them and wash
that [ __ ] down and try to get the flavor
out of your mouth
you know and it's funny because you deal
with
i had a teacher
that sold coke
and didn't tell me after i graduated
high school after like he knew i was
officially out
he came to me and then he was just
snorting garbage
let me show you what i got you know and
he was part of these people and he was a
white dude so he was like i deliver the
people that don't want a spanish dude
they call them yeah but they call me
right and tell me where to take it
so he was a [ __ ] nutcase but a good
guy i love to listen he won't friend me
on facebook
every every two years it ends i click on
the next [ __ ] day friend request he
just he just didn't like
i used to go and i used to go into the
city
and i had a dominican dude i had a
colombian dude in 1982 i already had a
[ __ ] my own personal colombians and i
would go over there and they had a disco
and it doubled as a coke place nice
and i until i went over and there was a
guy dead in front of the place i was
still selling coke yeah these guys were
real yeah
once you're you know that's the extreme
you know you deal with people who are
just people who have a day job
who like to go out on fridays and
saturdays and snort for free
and they sell coke they're just nice
people and they do you a favor
or you deal with you know there's such
an extreme that you bump into
as you're going through
in 84 i bought coke from time to time
from a colombian dude that put it in a
leaf
really oh he blew your mind
and unleashed all the white dudes used
to call him loco yeah okay and that's
what he was known as loco and he was
dark-skinned colombian yeah and when he
showed up to that bar right
he would have a thousand leafs yeah with
rope around them but it sucked because
then when he gave it
and he was getting [ __ ] in 84 that was
just right of course he could make you
go home pale
like he went home with no blood in you
like dracula came into that way it was
just [ __ ] terrible terrible times
whatever you think back at them but fun
you know you're like
i was having a fun time then snorting
for three days looking out a window
getting my dick sucked with dead dick
what are you going to do life goes on
thank god comedy saved our lives
yes gave us a direction
i think so uh
that was the uh
i think you know like what you the
reason you said you went into it i think
it's the only honest reason you know i i
wanted to do it and i didn't really like
anything else and i decided i didn't i
really even in my
comedy career i just don't listen to
people as much as i ought to sometimes
and i don't want to be told what to do
that much and
stand up and comedy offers you the
freedom to do kind of what you want and
with the minimum of people that you have
to deal with sort of and
that direction was uh way too appealing
every crop job i had i hated
my last job i was a schmendrick in a law
office i
you know sent faxes and you know i
pretended i was dead i remember for one
day laid on the floor because i hated it
so much and this is the even better part
you guys i'm pretending to be dead on
the floor and no one came in
and there's nothing sadder than when you
get up and you haven't even got the
reaction that you want like i wanted one
of the lawyers to walk in and go greg
what's going on let me go i can i can't
take it anymore and nothing nothing
i laid there
and then i got up
nobody gave a [ __ ] oh who [ __ ] and
all the lawyers then were doing a lot of
this was the 80s in san francisco they
were doing coke a couple of more
bouncing off the walls and then there
was the the guy whose firm it was and he
was a straight arrow and his father
worked there too and he was a straight
arrow but
one of the cats um had defended sunny
barger and sarah jane moore so i used to
go into his office his name was frank
bell i don't know if he's alive still he
was a uh
quite a good lawyer and um we would
smoke you know he closed the door and
we'd just smoke cigarettes and talk and
he would tell me like
what it was like sarah jane moore tried
to shoot president ford in san francisco
in front of the fairmont hotel in 1974.
and she got off i think around didn't
she before they knocked her down or
whatever something this and uh she might
have got off a couple and uh people were
shooting presents
squeaky from man uh uh uh sarah jane
moore both took a shot at uh um
president ford uh but they not i think
they or what squeaky form i think might
have attacked him with a knife
and they knocked her down and she is in
the manson family the seventies were
pretty you know and then uh
it's how i first got kidnapped when i
was in high school okay it started with
kennedy then his brother got shot right
now i still remember
i remember being a little kid some
people get shot for real yeah and then
the 70s brought in a complete difference
george wallace got shot in 72 george
wallace
who else something else well they should
they tried to shoot um uh
ford twice and that didn't work oh no
we're talking about breaking reagan got
shot in 80. haiti who else did they try
to shoot what presence other presidents
trying to get assassinated well every
president pretty much is if uh roosevelt
they tried a bunch of times uh andrew
jackson i think personally disarmed a
couple people that tried to kill him
uh
kennedy definitely
ford
yeah uh clinton and obama we don't know
i mean people do crazy [ __ ] and tried to
get break into the white house but
that's just crazy [ __ ] no nobody really
wants wow
yeah it's a very horrible history of
assassination which is why it's very
dangerous to say people should shoot
people and stuff because uh this is not
country four assassinated presidents and
at least eight or ten others that they
tried to kill
at different points and then every shot
castro
600 assassination attempts they said
that's [ __ ] and uh what was it it
took the year 2016 to kill him that's
what someone said
well castro you know
uh
the fact that we hadn't had relations
with them until last year is the part
that just blows my mind like really
you know he wasn't he hasn't been
what prime minister or premier or
whatever for what for a while now four
or five years his brother took over
right raul
you know
there's
he was a dictator so
positives are hard to find but i will
say he ejected the mafia out of cuba and
that might have been his greatest
accomplishment the revolution getting
america an organized crime out of cuba
was a vast undertaking i think at the
time uh
putting people in camps and prisoning
people with aids
not
not so great [ __ ] uh you know making
people leave
oh my god how many people are you listen
how many people are out there how many
people said you know what i can't take
the starvation and this
getting put in jail i'm just gonna get
on a [ __ ] rap and take a shot at
shark infested waters
yep how crazy is that that you would
take your [ __ ] child when he's two or
three like elian gonzalez you know go
we're leaving this [ __ ] nightmare
of a town you know i mean it was uh
it's a long time long long [ __ ] time
it's scary i think the best part is that
now that we've got relations with them
it's only enough
[ __ ] relations we got [ __ ] with them
well fidel closed that door and said
[ __ ] that pope and [ __ ] that and i
guarantee he said something derogatory
because he's cuban he said something
[ __ ] derogatory you don't want me to
say it on the show so
you know
he he just played along
he just played along you know fidel has
more money than god oh yeah you know and
he was also involved with the cartel i
mean when that guy went to prison he
went up in front of a judge he gave him
the the proof about fidel he goes listen
you guys were looking for the [ __ ] us
in colombia we were in cuba right we cut
a deal with him for 800 000 to ship
wow if we put the whole
ship filled with blow or two kilos he
got 800 000.
we were shipping him out of cuba
you know he made money on that he took
over all that
i don't know if he took over batista's
money
i think batista left with that game i
was going to say batista left with his
and maya lansky had his out as he was
coming in
maya lansky was having that wide through
rabinowitz burbinowicz and ben benoit's
office that was going right to a direct
[ __ ] why that wasn't even laying
around that one minute
it was very sad what fidel did and how
he did it you know uh he lied to these
people that were already getting beat up
for the last [ __ ] 10 years right you
know at the end of batista's reign
it was three years of hell you know
there was no police no more right they
just get out of cars and break your
[ __ ] skull and leave you there you
know there was no more they were
horrible and then came this guy
who promised you this and this
everyone's going to eat and also one day
he knocks on your door greg proofs and
says listen did you get the letter
you're like well
this house is part of the revolution
you got to go you know [ __ ] like this
and you're like where do i go i don't
know yeah that's your [ __ ] problem
there was just so many injustices and
then the 70s he really tightened up yeah
he really [ __ ] with those people and
that's what
when my mom died
one of the really big things that was
found was a letter from her family in
cuba
just basically [ __ ] denouncing her
and we got it
the day she died that was the mail that
was on the table oh my god she hadn't
even read it yet
so we're like and i remember my stepdad
calling me into the room and going come
here for a second
read this and i'm like what the [ __ ]
because what happened was when she sold
the bar
there was no other way to wire money to
that [ __ ] place for my sister so they
actually mail
uh checks and stuff and cuba was taking
half the money so my family thought my
mom
wasn't sending the right amount i mean
it was just a horrible night
we you know about a year ago about two
three years ago i opened up
communications with my sister you know
and one day i just asked i go what the
[ __ ] was going on at that time let me
tell you what was really going on okay
they had his brain washed
they had his brain washed they made us
believe that
we had a family in the united states
that were garbage we weren't allowed to
communicate with them
and those letters that were written were
written with them in the room like it
was one of those right right to tell
your relatives
yeah don't [ __ ] do this no more don't
do this no more don't do that no more
is it true i don't [ __ ] know i was in
new jersey with my own problems you know
um
for me it means that
this didn't affect me but in many ways
it did like i said i grew up with the
hatred around me
and then as i got old i said what am i
angry at this dude for
then i watched this tv show
celia
in the first 30 episodes it's fidel
taking over cuba little by little and
the promises he made
and how he had these young kids dedicate
themselves and uh and then i remembered
all the bad [ __ ] and then he dies last
[ __ ] week
so for me i just feel uh
happy for those people because there's a
lot of chapters lives for a lot of
people
what is it like for you to hear like
there's like the uh when people are pro
uh
or pro castro i can see like these are
there are people coming out who are like
he was did good things and that's just
like all i've heard was all terrible
things he did six great things
but he did 2 000
really bad things
see listen this country is already
forgiven
and i'm not picking out a scab
we've already forgiven
the guy who killed all the dogs
michael vick it's forgotten
america's on to more different problems
what the [ __ ] do you what the [ __ ] are
you mad about from 1959 yeah do you know
from 59 to 61 or 62 or something he was
cool
and then something went wrong somewhere
and he went [ __ ] ape [ __ ] and uh
that's when the gays started getting
killed then he became even more racist
and all this [ __ ]
and nobody nobody who even listens to
the podcast was there i wasn't there
right i wasn't there
but i saw the people's pain around me
i saw you know when i talked to you
about the san francisco 49ers you might
get a little hot with me but not that
your face gets red and you get tears in
your eyes and you have a vein in your
neck i saw those reactions from people
when cuba or fidel was brought up over
the holidays these people were shot
i come to your house liam boston
take you out of your house and you got
to leave your mother in boston and move
to california
and you don't know the language you
don't know how to get back you don't
even know the [ __ ] you are well what now
yeah it's pretty crazy what now it's
[ __ ] crazy so how many families he
broke up
you know
your mom is over there and you're here
but anytime you go home tomorrow you go
home
not there you know all those baseball
players that that uh defected defected
you know what they did to their families
and [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] things you know so
well there was no cubans in the bigs
from what 59 till
she whiz
like the 80s really that long
yeah
because remember when what's his name
the duke pitch for the yankees
he had defected
the last two i remember is louis t hunt
huh
but he left cuban like 61. i see what
you're saying you're absolutely correct
not that many players defected and were
able to play no if you look at if you
look at louis louis made a statement the
other day about the whole thing and
underneath it
told his story and it said that he left
cuba in 61. so you're absolutely right
and somebody else
tony perez bango you bad [ __ ]
you they don't even make them like great
proof no more they're great players man
and louis theon's father was also a
giant star in the caribbean and in the
negro leagues
uh
tiana used to give post-game press
conferences naked with a cigar
and uh he was fantastic he also almost
completely
on his pitching motion turned and faced
center field and then would deliver the
ball he had a tremendous motion i always
thought he should go in the hall of fame
he was like 250 wins and for money he
was really good
i felt that uh
i had no [ __ ] idea who he was
i was a tony perez fan because
tony perez and my dad grew up together
really in commonway cuba so after my dad
died whenever tony perez would come to
new york to play against the mets him
and my mom and his wife would get
together really and i was telling lee
in 73 the mets played the reds yeah
east coast in the whatever national
league
and i had the chicken pox so i couldn't
go to school my mom was like you might
as well come to the [ __ ] playoff
games
so i go to the one game and that's when
pete rose beat up on bud house yeah yeah
famous yeah tremendous i had to show lee
like you know this is just and i'm not
putting lead done at all there's no
reason for this one night lee and i had
a conversation we talked about pete rose
and how funny he was during the world
series this year
and the next day came in here like oh he
put on these videos i showed him
the all-star game video
very fossy it's it's
and this is like a tv show greg that i
think you and i need to pitch
let's
i just and this is not geo like we need
to go to not geo with this show and go
listen there's a generation of kids that
i had my friend bring their kids over
and they're 21 and i looked at them
like you guys ever see a bruce lee movie
and they looked at me and they go right
who's bruce lee and they go no not
really and i put on chinese connections
the second one when he goes to the
school and they kill the master that's
one of the best films ever [ __ ] made
the last 20 minutes that is pure torture
they were sweating their faces were red
i'm like you guys never saw this thing
like now there's a whole when elise told
me he had i totally grew up a real
hardcore baseball fan and somewhere
along the line you know leo stay up on
that computer all night somewhere along
the line he'd say what the [ __ ] did pete
rose why don't they put him in the hall
of fame and look it up and look at one
of his videos
so
i'm a cincinnati red fan [ __ ] die
hard
no you're not a yankees you're meant for
[ __ ] no my mom was a met fan and i would
go to the games i liked thom siva yeah i
liked uh there was a couple mats i liked
rusty stop my mom threw a chicken wing
at him what because she lost the game
my mom used to [ __ ] go to meg my mom
was listening cubans love baseball okay
yeah and when you bet the game that's a
completely different level of love yeah
and when you make an error and right
field we got a problem
so my mom would sit there eat the wings
and as he would run back she'd throw the
[ __ ] wings out and call him
all this [ __ ] and say [ __ ] to him
so i grew up uh i like baseball i like
going to
watch the pittsburgh pirates with willie
starjo and
back then i like the dodgers
dodgers were great when you lived tigers
were great say whatever the [ __ ] you
want the giants were great they had
willie mccovey i'm the giants and they
had my best very funny orlando surprise
[ __ ] right
they had uh i knew orlando's a painter
from santoria gathering really when i
was a kid yeah really and i used to play
baseball with his son
and i remember one like this he's out of
baseball already at this time not 70
late 70s no he played till 75. this is
73 yeah and he had a first baseman's
club i had baseball clubs
but i never had a first breath
so he was over there all weekend
we're playing baseball we're killing
chickens yeah you know we're doing the
whole [ __ ] thing and all of a sudden
the weekend ends
and i got the glove in my room and i'm
like he's gonna [ __ ] forget all right
just hit the dragon button this ain't
just a first baseman's glove this is a
[ __ ]
orlando savannah autographer
model no i don't even think it was
autographed no no i meant yeah yeah his
it was like rawlings orlando's a
pedophile they're in the car wave and
the kid goes home yeah i'll have my
glove i go you took it
and he's like no i didn't i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh you left in the room with your
t-shirt oh so yeah i [ __ ] up and i was
like god damn it yeah i almost had a
[ __ ] orlando pray to go wow
uh but i went to uh
the
one of the most thrilled my baseball
glove was a pete rose glove i loved all
that people [ __ ] i loved everything
about i loved that style of baseball
that aggressive
[ __ ] home runs all we need is a guy to
get on first to get this party started
type they would just torment baseball uh
pictures
but i love that style but by
my american league team
on the sly
was kind of the red sox
they had a pretty good team oh yeah i
[ __ ] hated the yankees i hated the
yankees and i hated their announcers
i think they grew up on wpix was mel
allen the announcer then i don't know no
i hate it i couldn't even listen phil
rizzuto oh red of course the scooter
forever oh [ __ ] yeah
so it wasn't like i was a big boston red
sox ramp that one tv i'd watch them
there were a couple play i always loved
carlton fisk he's great i just love
how's that his last game doug i love his
everything he was a red ass yeah like i
love his everything you know like uh
so i like that style of baseball and all
of a sudden they had to play the reds in
the world series
and my mom's tormenting me cuban style
yeah
you know human style so what are you
going to do now that you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] cincinnati reds
yeah you know
red is a girl's color what are you going
to [ __ ] do
and i'm living under this [ __ ]
torment
and i i just said listen put your
[ __ ] money with your mountains all
right
i win i live like a doctor i don't have
to do dishes i don't do my own laundry
no more all that shit's done and she's
all the time but it wasn't about that
with her
it was gonna be two or three months of
constant torture
and then everything like [ __ ] up she'd
go just the same way you like the reds
you know it's not too late you could
still be a boston rat like my mom was
one of those torture chambers my sheets
were going to be red
she was like i just tore them at me i
could not lose it wasn't about the money
it was about the dignity against a cuban
woman it's enough to destroy you
so when they played in the world series
i was in the [ __ ] dilemma
but
the boston red sox brought in
teont's parents from cuba came two game
three one of those games
and i never forgot the red sox for that
i said you know what
that's when fidel was hard
75 76 but that wasn't playing you got to
show up there with a big envelope yeah
boston restaurants is not known for big
payroll no
so for them to get t hunt's parents over
meant the world to me it was like he
gets a pitch in the world series you
know he did that documentary he went
back to cuba after 46 years and said
what a [ __ ] nightmare it was blah
blah blah blah blah
there's an article on vice about it
apparently it was the first time in 14
years that he pitched in front of his
parents
yeah yeah this is tremendous [ __ ] and
you know what i'm sorry guys you know
what i like sports from time to time
but i like good old american sports
i like good all-american sports i don't
need to see a pepsi commercial 85
[ __ ] times you know i like uh i grew
up on that and that stayed in my mind
and that's how i still remember sports
and that's how it should be played
how pete rose played the game do i agree
with his gambling not at all
but
i've been there what are you gonna do he
got caught
he paid his due to society he's still
one of the top
five players of all [ __ ] time
especially when the game got
and down and dirty that [ __ ] in the
all-star game till this day i'm 53 years
old
that hank aaron's home run yeah i
remember where i was it was in seventh
in bergen land avenue with my friend
digna's house with a little kid he hit
that home run
to me that was like [ __ ]
i i i was so excited from remember when
we were kids lou brock was a bad
[ __ ] oh yeah he used to steal
tons of basses and [ __ ] i love that i
had lube rock converse shoes who the
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with greg
proops some [ __ ] novice you think i
just
showed up with a [ __ ] uh a giant
shirt like oh my god i love that you
really have you know i love the giants
you're like really what's your favorite
team
last year's yeah you're like get the
[ __ ] out of my face amateur
today i'm not in touch with nothing
i told lydia a day
a friend came over and i watched a
little football and i watched uh not the
raider game was it the raid again
greater carolina
and that was the first time i had really
watched more than three minutes of
football yeah and i watched the game and
the whole time i'm like [ __ ] this a
great game
i go carolina's great the raiders have
been doing well
i was in this show the [ __ ] uh
carolina record knowing three and seven
or something
i'm like that's how much i know about
football right like i back 20 years ago
i knew stats quarterbacks
you know i think i stopped after
i ended football as like a [ __ ] san
francisco 49er fan when i was in high
school they won me a fortune when that
[ __ ] clark caught that ball i had the
over i had the niners
and that
that
pick not only got me that almost got my
knock my head knocked off because i got
really [ __ ] coked up that friday
night and really drunk when some kid
came in that me and him
didn't see eye to eye
and he kept talking about the [ __ ]
dallas cowboys and then my cocaine hates
this kid could have killed me yeah i
looked at him like a listen
let's put a thousand down you know i
didn't have two dollars in my pocket but
that's how much
i knew the niners were gonna win
because they were getting a point at
home no you're not coming into my
[ __ ] house the only team i lost to
this year was those [ __ ] new orleans
saints that stayed in my ass for years
the nighters couldn't figure out how to
beat the [ __ ] saints
what about the niners not to uh i don't
want to uh depress you but they just
really they went from super bowl
contender to
i think they have one win we're in a
rebuilding phase now as they say
i don't understand super bowl teams and
teams that go far when you
then the management goes okay this is
what we invested all this money for was
that moment it didn't happen break up
this [ __ ] team let's start anew with
a new budget i never understood that
medallion sports all that type of time
carbon wasn't a good fit for san
francisco either and nobody really liked
him and they were pretty much glad to
see a guy who got us to the super bowl
and the playoffs glad to see him go also
that super bowl was a horrible super
bowl and
that one seemed like there was
gangster's hands all over it when the
[ __ ] lights went off at the superdome
at the halftime for 20 minutes and then
they're like oh
now new orleans is ice cold and we came
back and scored what three touchdowns
and still couldn't win it i just thought
i remember the last super bowl i
remember standing drunk screaming at the
screen from three inches away as we lost
let me tell you something i remember the
last 15 super bowls like i remember
getting raped
like i just don't remember them at all i
give them something i just that's how
much no i don't watch that that's how
nine is what i watched that's how
different my life was there was a time
where right you'd watch a super bowl man
the grandmother
a case of being three quaaludes and that
was just the start yeah that was just
half time at columbia in the third
quarter because we might need something
i want you to deliver i was one of those
type of guys and now i know nothing
i i know zero about baseball baseball is
the one that i can't even keep up with i
don't even try anymore it's been like
three years
because it's just too much but you'll
watch a red sox fan well you stop
watching the red sox
if i if it's on fox but i don't have
like the local boston station so i'm not
gonna do that and then it's just the
players change so much i i always go
when i'm home
but other than that it doesn't seem
it's just a hundred it's 162 games
before the playoffs so i just six months
yeah oh my god
you got time to follow that when you're
15. yeah i was going to say i don't
follow it as obviously as i do you read
the whole i'm known as a baseball fan
but i really like all time baseball more
and also yeah now i don't have time
every day to follow every single team in
the bigs and what they did and who their
players are
and this year yes because the giants
staggered into the playoffs and also i
was on the road with joel murray i'm in
an improv group with him and he's you
know the biggest cubs fan in the world
so
i had someone i could root for that you
know when the cubs beat the giants it
was like fine i watched it i watched a
few of those games
it's uh it's just amazing to me how i
went from knowing
the only one i did not there was two
sports i could not talk to you about
ever and that's hockey yeah i don't know
nothing about hockey i went through a
few games
seemed interesting right
and college football moved too fast for
me
it was too complicated there was too
many teams there were teams that i
zeroed in on and watch and then people
would say no watch these guys and watch
but besides that i couldn't keep up with
college football if it was on and i went
at lee's house or i'm at your house i'd
say put the [ __ ] game where we
watching this [ __ ] anything is better
you know when you're 19 anytime better
than [ __ ] division 9 yeah you know
could be anything better than what the
[ __ ] you're playing or whatever so
but now
i know the tv service i have there's
like so many games they have high school
football no for god's sakes
yeah i don't know it's just not as much
of an obsession anymore like you say you
kind of i don't know i don't know if
it's getting older or what i mean if
it's the giants
or the niners then i'm
more interested and i go to a couple
baseball games every year and i watch a
few i still follow it
but not
like when i was first on the road 20
years ago or whatever
there was a
when you had to follow it in the
newspaper
uh you know you get the paper in the
morning and you read all the stats and
read the standings and read all the game
wrap-ups and then you know then the
sports center started and then you'd you
know you could see all the baseball
highlights which you never could before
you had to watch crappy local news which
would have two minutes of nothing
and now it's so much people are on their
phone every second
i don't know my father was a compulsive
gambler and the one thing he didn't that
was sports
sports was not his horses he liked
horses but he he called sports bettors
bleeders
because you have to wait three hours
to lose
that that's what i like about it a bunch
of [ __ ] bleeding horse race is over
in two minutes two minutes and you know
exactly where you stand
and whether you're gonna play the next
race
but with sports it's all day sunday all
weekend and then you can you can really
blow it out betting sports it's funny i
like gambling
but i did not understand
losing money
and i did not understand working hard
and giving half your check away three
quarters of it away
i go to the track twice a year up here
i take 50 60 bucks with me you got a
bowl of chili a beer yeah and when the
60 disappears you get in your car and go
home right
but that's not what real hardcore
gamblers do no they're they're there to
be alive every night no but i learned
because i also went to the track and won
900 and all of a sudden lost and had to
walk home right that was a horrible
lesson for me as a young man
and then sports betting
it's a great idea where i'm from until
you get in trouble with it right and
then you gotta lean down for a few years
and you know hopefully they forget by
that and then you move on but once i got
out of that [ __ ]
once i left jersey and all those years i
probably put in ten bets
and five of them were for six of them
i've been in vegas
two of them have been here [ __ ]
around or whatever but no no no no
that's a horrible life to get involved
oh yeah on top of the drugs i was
already doing i can't have 19 [ __ ] drugs
and gambling oh yeah you're gonna burn
in hell for a long time yeah you need a
bankruptcy for the [ __ ] bankruptcy
what's up lee look at the shapey
i'm doing okay no you know what's
happening
you go to bed sweetie
look at the shape of youtube hey what do
we have don't worry about that at least
at least
yourself
what are the da's listen they're coming
to rescue you need that aggravation that
you like the dna is listening they
should have been here a while ago does
this show go out live to the dea yeah
live feed straight to the dna yeah yeah
i should think so at this point can i
ask you something if you don't want to
talk about that i understand all right
lee but you were bob the builder yeah
that's pretty cool like i'll talk about
bob the builder it's like a kit like
it seems like to be hot with the under
fives dad like it'd be like the a star
of the kids show it's pretty cool i got
it uh years ago uh 10 years ago maybe we
did a 2004 2005 2006 and ended around
there somewhere
uh i went in at uh to a studio in london
there was a company called hit that used
to make the show
uh neil morrissey who is a british
actor was the british bob the builder he
had kind of a paul mccartney you know
northern
he took like this you know it's well
done wendy and uh
i went in and i was doing all these
funny voices and then a woman came over
the speaker and she goes um uh would you
mind just doing it in your voice
and i said are you insinuating that i
have a funny cartoon voice
and
so what if you would mind reading again
just yourself
so i went
well done wendy you reduced and you
recycled
and um they were like come out and then
uh
this is the only time it's ever happened
to me jelly
i went out into the studio
and she goes
well we've been having a chat and um
would you like to do it would you like
to be bob
and i was like oh i'd love to that'd be
fantastic terrific
thank you that's great i should cancel
everybody walked out the door on the
phone immediately my voice agent in
london
[ __ ] call them back right now before
they [ __ ] think about it before they
change their mind
call them that now they they just
offered me the [ __ ] part so i did it
for years and i would fly to london and
we'd record like a couple dozen shows
and it was a studio in soho i would go
around the corner to bar italia and have
coffee in the morning and then i go
upstairs at lunch we'd have curry or
chinese food from a take out eater
it was a fantastic gig and then people
would say to me craig ferguson said it
to me
why don't they just record it here
you know why don't you just record it in
l.a and i'd go shh
what do you mean why don't we record in
l.a they're flying me and my wife to
london a couple three times a year to
record this cartoon they might be
bugging me don't say that right and so
we would get a trip to london i put gigs
with it
you know and
uh we went to the world cup i remember
with drew carey in 2006 to do this tv
show for like discover
and uh i went and i did bob the builder
and
our our engineer was a really nice guy
he had a bad day this day and um
he erased an entire day's worth of
recording right which was probably 16
shows you know
16 20 cartoons
and so i get a my agent rings me
um could you come back to london
i'm like well i'm in the middle of kind
of going to these football matches and
i'm doing a tv show here and they're
like oh no they're going to pay you
again for all of them
uh
the engineer erased an entire day's
worth of recording and you've got to
come back in and do it so i was flown
from frankfurt i think
to london and i went and did one day
and the same engineer
no they fired him he was in hell he was
really nice i loved him you won't see
him he came to ride he came to the show
once uh we were playing the comedy store
with the improv group and uh he came out
to the show he was oh you're doing the
shutting on you know another phone you
see it so i'm like hey i'll put you at
the door for you right so he comes to
the show you know i've been working with
him all day doing bob
and
he
as we say in england rad artist i mean
he [ __ ]
you know hey man how's it going that guy
[ __ ] plays
like i was like wow honey you put it on
before you know like this is a two-hour
improv show and he was yeah completely
rad asked and uh so bob the builder was
great and then they sold the company and
that was that and then but i did it for
four or five years and uh
it was really fun the guy they had
before me i never liked and i don't know
who does it now
um
but people are like why don't you do it
again it's like that's not how anything
happens that's not how anything works um
but i really enjoyed doing it and we did
a feature film too and that one we did
from here that one i remember doing from
here and susie quattro isn't it you
remember susie quattro susie quattro was
one of the voices in bob the builder in
this episode i don't think she was wendy
but she was like a cowgirl or something
she was a rock star in the 70s a glam
star she made it big in england then she
came back to the states and was leather
tuscadero was it on happy days
she was from detroit she was just a
rocker girl from it was pinkie tuscadero
there was pinky and then i think leather
was her sister's sister yes and not
susie quadra but uh
yeah so bob the builder thank you for
asking uh so people go will you do the
bob the builder voice and i'm doing it
this is the bob to build a voice the
only difference would be i go lee
well done you recycled
thank you and they go and then so
because it was a british cartoon and we
were doing it for north america
uh they lived in a caravan so i go you
know that's a trailer
and they would drink tea and i'm like no
coffee you know and every once in a
while something would slip through and
they'd they'd have rewritten it for
north america and i'd go we don't say
bits we say parts
part of it
they they say oh you know bits and that
and it's like we go
i have a part this part goes here
and every once well i'd have to go like
you if you want it to sound like
americans talking
we go i'm going to the trailer to get
some coffee not i'm nipping over to the
caravan for some tea or whatever right
right
so
i would say like you know we can't say
this and then especially in construction
right and he's he's a he's a
construction worker and then there was i
can't remember the valley they lived in
i can remember some of the names
uh muk was one of the characters and
skip
an uh
a bucket a water bucket in england is
sometimes called the butt b-u-t-t and
one of the episodes i said to my wife
was like a porn episode muck's water
butt
uh but it just meant mux water bucket
and [ __ ] and then uh
so
they would play it for me with the
english version
and that was what i recorded too
we all came in separately and the other
actors in it were all canadian in
general uh in london when they can't
find americans to do american voices
they
use canadians because canadians sound
enough like us to do it and and star
wars too uh me and scott kapoor were
both in san francisco they used us
because they wanted they recorded in
london but they wanted the pod race to
have american voices and i'm doing bad
ron fairly if you remember ron fairley
played for the dodgers played for the
expos he was the giants announcer in the
80s and he was incoherent and uh
ron falling goes well here comes mark
grant out wait i'll scratch that that's
uh
that's mark davis like he would get
players confused and show like that you
know and mark davis was left-handed and
mark grant was right-handed and you're
like how did you how when they were out
there throwing
so when i went in to do the star wars
one they're like do a announcer voice so
i just went like
wow what a day it is here today like
because that's how ron philly did i
thought yeah i remember you know wait uh
we go have beers with the sandy kofax
was a heck of a guy and you know like
he would just go off yeah
so
like cubs cubs fans always do uh harry
kerry harry carey right right like
there's 500 comics uh camp kemp nera in
particular well known for his harry
kerry but um
every chicago cubs fan i know can do
harry carry
i don't do a very good one but uh maybe
no but i so i did a baseball nose for
that one but um yeah thank you for
asking about bob the builder i don't
mind talking about it all right i people
would go like did you like doing it and
it's like they'd fly me to london and
then we'd have like curry at lunch
like
what do you mean did i like it and all
you had to do was read scripts you know
and do a [ __ ]
thing yeah and then no camera and i work
fast and i like to work fast i'm sure
you do too yeah so and the producer was
cool and we had the same taste in music
so in between breaks we'd talk about
music and [ __ ] and uh he was a musician
a threaded musician he was recording
cartoons for a living and nada
we would knock off they would schedule
two full days in the studio and we'd be
done in like a day sometimes or a day
and a little bit of a morning and then i
was free you were afraid yeah but you'd
be booked out for like three days and
like
i'd do it all in a day a day and a half
because you know if you work fast and
just put your head down
and of course every take they're they're
signing off on every take they're not
although i will tell you one about star
wars when we finished it and i whenever
that movie came out 96 or 97
uh
we were brought back in
uh to studio in london
and i'd recorded in london and this and
that
and uh i went in and there was a phone
patch and there was a guy in marin at
lucasfilm on the other end of the line
and they played the pod race and i did
all the lines over again and you know
how when you're recording something they
go okay do it again and hit this part of
the line and make this part good
[ __ ] i go when does the picture open
and the guy on the other end goes
ten days
so
i read the line well yeah that's gotta
hurt or whatever and they're like fine
moving on right one pass one pass
one pass
on everything
their picture was opening literally in
ten days and they were getting last
[ __ ] that's how they do it and this
big show how much the picture cost a
zillion i mean now it would cost a
million zillion but then it cost a
zillion dollars that's what i was amazed
about uh going back to bob the builder
that you could do an entire season in a
day
and they wouldn't have rewrites every
two like two minutes but these had
already been done and they were already
british cartoons so i was voicing them
over for re-release in canada and the
united states oh so all the pbs stations
on cam or whatever you know cbc what not
i don't know where it should encounter
but like the north american market
required american voices
in their mind and so it was fine
and i i i loved doing it and i would do
it again in a second
i don't get to do enough cartoons
i know now i sound like a mr showbiz i'm
just telling me sorry well you asked and
i thought well [ __ ] it listen man
one of the things that's always
attracted me to you like
was you watch the departed there's a
great scene the movie departed where he
asked leonardo dicaprio jack nicholson
if uh
he knew who john lennon was yeah and he
goes you know one says he could take a
tuba and get something out of it
i always
thought that as comedians
we should always be more versatile
i always believe that when i see a guy
who's doing that
i admire him for going outside the box
because there's so many guys that just
write
go on the road and that's it
and they work that angle
that would just kill me
if that was it that that'd be like
getting a [ __ ] die might as well just
go to new york and carry a brown bag and
it's the same [ __ ] difference my
friend
it's the same [ __ ] difference
i could just go to the funny bone in
memphis so many times before you want to
put a gun in your phone yeah yeah yeah
you try to split it up and there's your
chicken wings in the dressing room the
friday night let's show you all right
and then as you go
doing
as you get wiser and older you go you
know what this is like a [ __ ] loan
shark i got to milk these clubs for
everything they got instead of going
every 18 months i go every two years and
i make a bigger splash you just learn
how to milk your [ __ ] money you know
but
i like that that you could do a
voiceover and call somebody go you know
what i gotta cancel that week in
poughkeepsie
yeah that's heaven when you get
something oh
i'll call you next year and it's healthy
to do from time to time to let people
know you got them in check you know what
i'm saying sometimes you got to keep
these club owners in check whatever have
a great time
but it's so
i would die if all i had was comedy and
the last couple years i gotta do the
podcast because it wasn't how it used to
be five years ago for me i would book a
film for six weeks
and that's when you call everybody and
go scratch that date sorry charlie i'm
focusing on this film even if it wasn't
a ton of money it didn't matter to me i
took that break just because i could
take that break trust me by the second
week you start bringing a notebook on
the set right and writing little jokes
and [ __ ] but until then it's a nice
little cleanse you know you need that
i never uh liked i like people who have
different things going on i could tell
they're more creative well i got lucky
with a bunch of stuff too but yes it it
really no but you were at the right
place at the right time
even when they offered to you you could
have turned it down voiceover because i
can't wait so i just got the wrong guy
you know somebody called me for a
voiceover i didn't know what to do
you're like are you [ __ ] crazy jack
like i just did mafia three
and then my first little live action
voice blew my mind
well i like to do it again uh
yeah i like that it wasn't bad cause i
do it every day it gets on your [ __ ]
nerves well there's people who do do it
every day uh okay and they [ __ ] carry
suitcases to the bank tony montana
they finally get studios in their houses
those are the ones that really rocked my
life right the ones that said you know
what i just bought a house right and i
drew it all from here i got a studio
right from the back so i go in there in
the morning i read i email them the
files and the river derchi that said
it's over those are the guys that are
just geniuses yep
did you see nightmare before christmas
uh
he's limited you don't say he's gonna
have to eat an edible every
eyeballs are going to be [ __ ] red i
eat i need an edible every day
regardless are you talking about like
the one
that it wasn't an older one like in the
90s or 80s yeah oh yeah then yes yes i
didn't see that one i didn't know if
there was a new one no they haven't
remade it
well i got lucky this year and last year
and uh danny elfman did it we did it
live at the hollywood bowl so i got to
do that over halloween and that was
really fun
joey it was like being in an opera man
that was like
there's a full orchestra on stage 20
people in the chorus there was five
singers i was one of them because i was
in the movie
and um
and danny who had done the music and
everything he came out and sang
catherine o'hara pee wee herman
ken paige it was and so they'd show the
film then they stop it and they'd
introduce a number and then everybody
come out and sing it
and full orchestra and so we do
rehearsals with just us and then you'd
rehearse with this [ __ ] symphony
orchestra and i'm in front of all the
strings and the
cellos are behind me and everything
and
you know it just
comedy is fun and comedy's worthy and i
love doing comedy and it's you know the
emotional core of my life but getting to
do something like that i felt like i was
in [ __ ] rigoletto you know what i
mean like
it's just this giant undertaking and
they're showing the movie and the
crowd's going crazy and there's 18 000
people there because it's the hollywood
bowl and million kids you know and
everybody's dressed up and stuff and
they asked me this year will you host
the costume contest before the show
last year they had a dj or somebody do
it like a little girl
i'd have been a little girl but i mean a
young woman dj from like disney channel
or something
and uh of course she's not funny
you know you go you're parading a bunch
of people up and [ __ ] dressed like
all the characters from nightmare
and uh so i said yeah i'd love to
i go before the show i'm sitting
downstairs you know what i mean i'm not
doing anything
an hour before the show let's put my
costume on early
and i go up and all these people in
these elaborate [ __ ] outfits you know
dressed as skellington jack or
or wednesday adams or whatever the [ __ ]
you know
uh monsters from beetlejuice little a
little kid four-year-old kid gets up
and he's dressed as beetlejuice and i go
what's your name and he goes
jack and i'm like jack and he goes um he
pulls him in and what is it he goes
jacques
and i go you're going to do a lot better
in a few years with jack than you are
with jack man let me tell you that and
then he pulls me down i go what is it
and he goes
have i won yet
now how long was this whole process at
the hollywood bowl well we rehearsed for
like uh two or three times uh at various
places the year before we did costume
fittings and all that and and then we
did three nights at the hollywood bowl
um and the year before we did two nights
at the hollywood bowl
uh john massieri who's the conductor of
the hollywood orchestra was the
conductor and i was posted up like where
lee is is where the conductor was on the
podium with his baton and i was right
here so yeah he would look over like
you'd be coming on and he'd go
when you're apart yeah right at you
and uh
i missed my cube hideously one night of
course
and uh then the next night i got it
right and i said to him afterward having
a beer how was it and he's like that was
exciting wasn't it
the first year when we rehearsed we were
all chattering because we're idiots and
i was with singers these are real songs
you're getting anxiety just listening to
you right now honest real like breathing
i have to sing with real singing i've
seen blood right
feeling the energy from an orchestra on
my neck
playing horns and violins yes especially
at the hollywood bowl the way the sound
goes out because my wife used to work
there so we'd go there for all the pink
panthers and all that stuff like that
and i was always amazed how this like i
would always go thank god i'm not on
heroin right now thank god i'm not an
acid right now that would have been a
big [ __ ] mistake you know
it uh i couldn't imagine doing what you
did right now until i started yakking at
you i was going down
and it felt like i was bleeding like why
am i feeling this way am i bleeding from
something yeah
that's how much anxiety i was getting
from you just saying
you know
we rehearsed and uh i got it wrong a few
times this time and all the singers had
remembered it from last year and they
wrote us an email like do you need a new
book and i remembered i had the book
right it's the music book with all the
lyrics and
and i can't read sheet music so it's no
[ __ ] good to me like the words you
know
the tune i had to memorize be you know
play the songs over and over
uh because i can't read sheet music and
of course the singers in the show are
that's what they do for a living they
sing so they can read if you give them a
sheet of music they'll
go you know and then oh no no i need to
diminish fifth and then on the second
bar i need you to um you take the high
part and you take the little part and i
want you to do a low seat and they go
and i'm like you know i don't [ __ ]
so uh but it wasn't as complicated as
all that but the first year we were in
the rehearsal room at warner brothers
with a giant orchestra and we were
yapping
and john missouri the conductor went
like this and it hadn't happened to me
since i was a little kid
he didn't say a word and even look at us
he didn't say a word he just went like
that
like we were children right and i
all five of us just at attention you
know because we were blah blah blah blah
blah and you know they're trying to do
something
and that one made me let go you you know
focus greg focus that was this is a
different game yeah this is a [ __ ]
different game there's two hundred this
is in this room yeah this isn't and
you're pulling that attention towards
yourself right now with jokes this isn't
this yeah i don't think so this is
you know the problem i saw as soon as i
moved to l.a
and i always spoke about this
was going on a set
and in basketball
when i first moved here one of the
biggest blessings i got was
in those days when you got two days in
the film it was really 32 days
because they go i don't know what we're
gonna put your scenes coming tomorrow
so i saw people go in there
and i forget the comic that went in
there when he left like they applauded
they couldn't wait for him to leave yeah
because he was directing
he was a writer
let me write the scene for you the right
way and i always learned from watching
that to shut my [ __ ] blind hole
even when people come over i yes them
and no right
they're paying me
this is not stand up
this isn't and don't be the center of
attention yeah this guy is paying me to
be part of uh yeah you know again we're
talking about hollywood situations
remember your lines don't stand in the
right place the last 18 months
greg i've been getting anxiety at the
store
soon as i walk into the original room
been going there for 20 years this
february soon as i walk up the stairs
i look at the stage
my heart [ __ ] whatever okay so that
was one thing
i did it a few times i just breathed
through it by the time i hit the stage
i'm fine i did the goddamn comedy jam
have you done it yet
a lot of fun same thing
i went up there confident as [ __ ] as i
was walking onto the stage out of my
right eye i could see all these people
jumping up and down i just had to look
at the drummer and sing for the trouble
and when i did turn around my just my
heart stopped
you know i was like what the [ __ ]
that was funny did the will turn theater
a couple weeks ago i almost fell apart
right yeah
first two minutes i was out of it yeah
yeah i was like joey breathe through
this [ __ ] you know
you're talking about going up at the
hollywood [ __ ] bowl
singing with an orchestra behind you i'm
sitting here going
i would die at this point in my life
maybe 10 years ago
10 years ago i could definitely [ __ ]
do whatever the hell i wanted to and
that's
i [ __ ] hate talking about this [ __ ]
the longest yard is on constantly
and every time it's on i catch the
beginning or i catch one particular
scene
you ever you ever you have hbo yeah all
four of them yeah yeah and you leave the
house and
spiderman is on night and it's always up
to a certain point and you always leave
at that point and then you come back the
next day it starts from that point
you're like what the [ __ ] going on in
my life
whenever i see the longest yard and i
don't know it's on i put on like
something 2 45 to see if lo and all is
on
and as i'm scrolling it's on the comedy
center at two in the afternoon yeah and
it's always the first scene that i pop
out and the second thing where i really
have lines yeah okay
and every time i look at that scene
i have to switch it because
i get so much anxiety thinking about
doing that scene
for the first time in front of everybody
like me getting to albuquerque me
getting to santa fe
me rehearsing me working out with the
team yeah all that [ __ ] in that dick
compared to like they were monday 6 a.m
and also oh by the way you're the first
scene on monday and group
and michael irvin and all these football
players and camera guys and that masala
and chris rock
i you know i and i wasn't doing blow
either when i got to albuquerque i said
i'm uh santa fe i'm not cop and blow i
broke down the sixth week i'm not gonna
lie
but the first three weeks i wanted just
to look good and be healthy you know
but i look at that scene nelly
and i get anxiety
watching yeah right right
what team was it the one in the
beginning wow
what is it about do you know what i'm
desperate to use the bathroom it's not
terrible no no no no i got to do some
shout outs all right guys go do your
thing you know what scene it is
it's the scene when
can you fit around here i can you're
beautiful it's the scene when
he goes when i read the [ __ ] board
treehouse oh okay guys that scene right
there as soon as i see that
my heart [ __ ] stops
it beats heavy
and i can't believe i had the balls to
do that
and i try to think back at what the [ __ ]
i was thinking at that time
that made me think i could do that scene
because today thinking about that scene
i would quit right [ __ ] there
right that day when i would have walked
on the set i would have ran to the
director and said listen sir
i hate to tell you this
there's no way i can [ __ ] do this
okay
there is no way
i can [ __ ] do this why would you do
that to yourself because that's the way
my mind works okay
what the [ __ ] was i thinking i'm a fat
felon from north bergen new jersey who
robbed and stole
i can't believe
[Music]
when i got the call for that and i can't
believe when they called me and said i
actually had it
like i kept walking around thinking a
[ __ ] brick was gonna hit me or
something so you didn't you didn't think
that like since they chose you like it
was fine
i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was
thinking it doesn't really matter that's
how bad my anxiety like when i see that
scene my [ __ ] heart stops though
anyway joe perez gets a shout out bob
lingas and his family gets a shout out
tommy easter making a comeback
out of the [ __ ] hills and [ __ ] lorne
rosencott my man ron mcfadden ronnie
archer dom de niro john cutler
todd lightly and john petrowski i love
you [ __ ]
don't forget this weekend portland
oregon and [ __ ] the party starts
thursday night eight o'clock don't [ __ ]
around i don't want to hit no tears
and tears for fears and all this [ __ ]
and don't forget [ __ ] cso tv
you basically 10 days away from my first
special i'm happy you got my back all
you got to do right now when that
podcast ends
go to cso tv do your email do the code
and do a code name joey and get two
months for free you're helping me out so
do me that favor and call your mother
give her the [ __ ] code
call your sister give her the code call
your brother give another code call
anybody the [ __ ] you know all right and
while i got you here right now real
quick i want to tell you about a nice
christmas tree i like these people i
like the product they got a 60-day
guarantee
hellotushy.com all right listen like
i've told you once i told you a thousand
times but days are back baby there's no
more reasons to be walking around with
that stink ass all embarrassed a hairy
muffler
if you don't know what a bidet is it's a
device that sprays your butt clean with
water agua nice
i grew up with a bidet all right they
are [ __ ] tremendous right now i got a
big day in the back bathroom
unfucking believable um my wife finally
installed it it's a party they also sent
me towels
hellotushy.com got towels [ __ ]
thanks to tushy's new sleek bidet that
clips on the existing toilet you hear me
existing no plumbers no nothing it
sprays your butt completely clean with
fresh water to get your muffler [ __ ]
sparkly
[ __ ] nuts you know listen when you
sit there on afternoon what do you think
happens to your muffler bacteria grows
hemorrhoids you get yeast infections
basically you get rotten [ __ ] ass how
you gonna go on that date and go to
sushi and then go to the movies with
that [ __ ] filth developing your
[ __ ] muffler okay that all comes to
an end with hellotushy.com
right the days are better for the
environment also there's no paper means
no trees die it uses one pint of water
per [ __ ] [ __ ]
so every time you take a dump once you
put the button
one pile of water hits your muffler
think about
sitting there on christmas [ __ ] day
with water hitting your little muffler
as you drift afloat into the [ __ ]
stratosphere you understand me do me a
favor cut this [ __ ] all right not only
that tushy stands behind their product
for 60 days this is
the original [ __ ] stocking stuffer
hellotushy.com right now
go get yourself a bidet right now you
got somebody what he needs another
[ __ ] towel what does he need another
book another cd
give him a big day see how happy he gets
go to
hellotushi.com right now i'm going to
give you 10 off all right right now
today 60 day
guarantee and also they got the gold
tushy towels when you're finished it
wipes your little [ __ ] muffler
spotless nobody knows nothing there's no
fingerprints you understand what are you
staring at me like that
hellotushy.com slash church all right mr
proof get in here let's close this
[ __ ]
get a little bit more info what's going
on in the world
i gotta lose some anyway
well joe it's always a pleasure with you
and lee
it's always a [ __ ] pleasure seeing
you i'm happy that you're working i was
happy to hear about the hollywood bowl
that [ __ ] uh makes my dick hard man
these people just tap out and they go
one direction
listen you gotta we're working eight
[ __ ] things here a podcast
we're working on the road career we're
trying to get a tv show going we're
trying whatever whatever the [ __ ] we got
you got to work it from right direction
until they put us in the casket that's
it
there's no retiring
no what are you going to do once you
once you stop using it brother you lose
it that's it it's all over then your leg
starts going your little feet start
going
i'll find somewhere to crack jokes
there's somebody who always give me 25
bucks
to tell them a few jokes
they have a drink i have a [ __ ] diet
coke they think i'm really drinking you
know what i'm saying old school style
working at lisa what do you got planned
this week emily
[ __ ] uncle joey what's the adventure
this weekend
you gonna go horseback rent
no maybe um
there is a pretty cool uh vintage uh
arcade in pasadena that i might go to
look pretty fun and i hate that
um i don't hate nothing i just like what
you do i'm interested because you're
such an interesting fellow
who would i have this weekend you sit
there you think of all these things you
know what i've been to an arcade in 30
years
maybe i go to a [ __ ] arcade this
weekend it's cool to learn free play
hold on let me
let me yelp this and see if there's an
arcade in the area oh what a coincidence
it's [ __ ] arcadiaville up there even
better there was a groupon so
did you god look at you hell yeah
he's a victim of youth i love the little
things
the little things it's everything's at
his fingertips
everything's yelp he don't take a chance
right
everything is yellow people leave
strangers yeah he listens to strangers
but he won't listen to his uncle joey
ain't that a [ __ ]
some guy on yelp he's never met
thousands all the popeyes chicken this
[ __ ] model go down and get the
popeyes you were the one who told me to
get popped by his
i'm not talking about popeye's chicken
it's just a [ __ ] example all right
i'm gonna tell you to get popular why
i told him to get papa he goes i think
he gets three buckets i didn't tell you
that i don't get three buckets look at
the i got the spicy ones okay
this is what i live with you understand
me this is what i like it's the pizza
rev i don't know what to do no more what
else you got going on brother
you're traveling you're doing oh yeah
i'm in yeah i'm in yuck yucks and then
i'm back in um we're gonna share the
apartment over at the senate family on
december 7th uh the great group's film
club
uh that's a great picture with jack
lemon and shirley mclean old school
brother oh yeah old school
teaching and teaching the kids baby
and um
then in uh let's see then in london if
your
listeners have uh london they'll be on
the 14th i'll be at the comedy store the
common store clears on the 17th i'll be
at the soho theater
then i'll be at shakespeare company in
paris on the 20
something somewhere in there i don't
know if that's a live show i don't know
if we're just gonna do it in a room and
drink
uh
and then um
back in san francisco for new year's
for new year's weekend a podcast then
too
where are you at new year's eve san
francisco punchline
what great what's great service no with
me just oh you got the punchline yeah
there's a punchline they're at
cops probably they do the yeah yeah
there's
across like a mile away right
hilariously as you know just go so small
the clubs are like
literally five minutes from each other
i'm a punchline guy i'm with you we've
had this discussion yeah yeah yeah yeah
cubs is big and it's not yeah they they
wanted me to do it again and then yeah
they push it every [ __ ] time listen
cobb is available the 26 you'll make a
ton of money listen i like the little
room you get the [ __ ] punch line
leave me the [ __ ] alone move on with
your goddamn line it's my home it's my
homeboy
last new year's i i improvised the whole
set and i didn't like to go out of my
way and tell anyone i just got up there
and did it because i was tired of
hearing my material one and uh two with
the album oh i meant yeah i made that
one the year before why you still get
the record um
no no no the uh but last year instead of
uh
you know i just thought well i'll just
get up there and riff and you know the
clock was there and the decorations and
everything so
it was a lot more fun it was a lot more
fun than trying to you know 10 minutes
till new year's people aren't focused
anymore they they want that you know
then it's weird up there trying to sell
you materials right you know come on so
you're actually [ __ ] sick of yeah
that's the concept people never never
get that you're like me you love to
write you switch [ __ ] up you take a
chance at the beginning of your set
sometimes you bury yourself i love all
that [ __ ] in a set i can't go out there
and do the same set just to have a great
set i gotta take chances sometimes i go
down the dark street and i gotta work
myself out of it that's where 25 years
comes in
you know
my first
16 months in the business
i realized after three months
that it was very hard to write a new
five minutes every week
you know my first year in the business i
thought i was actually oh yeah i'll
write five minutes every week every
tuesday i have a brand new five minutes
yeah [ __ ] surprise jack
so i improvise
and i learned
but it took me a long time to make the
switch over to
stand-up comedy i would just go on stage
do one or two jokes
and start with uh what do you do for a
yeah right right and it gets [ __ ] old
yeah it's a 50-50 you're not a comedian
anybody could do that [ __ ]
until one day i got serious in seattle
at the contest and i stopped improvising
and i don't improvise at all like i
improvise on stage yeah but to go on
stage and talk to the audience i can't
do that no more oh i never talked to the
crowd i'll move that [ __ ] train
fast if it happens
but for so long i was depending on it
what a horrible crutch to have
and when you see somebody doing it when
you're going to do a show and you see
somebody doing it it makes you think
when you were doing that [ __ ] you're
like god damn it years ago uh tom sawyer
who ran the old cobs in san francisco
said to me i was probably opening at the
time
uh
you can't follow yourself
and i said what do you mean he goes
you do your jokes then you go into the
crowd and you work the crowd for 10
minutes and then when you come back to
your jokes everybody can smell your
material
and that's not that funny
like you know he didn't get on me for it
he just said
what time it was right right he said you
can't follow yourself
you've got to write more material that's
about this and that and i went you're
right i'm relying so hard on where
you're from when you know you're an
idiot
and it was like and so then i just
stopped talking the crowd entirely you
know lee said that he only met people
that smoked pot it's so weird
when i was doing coke i would bump into
somebody
somewhere in every town that
miraculously had a grandma yellow on
them you attract it you always say to
yourself how come with heroin
people with heroin don't bump into me
it's so weird when you improvise
pretty soon people
smell it on you and they start chatting
up
before you even get there
that's where it turns sour on you
that pretty soon it's not that you're
known for improvising you just
give off that vibe that allows them
to come in right which you don't want
that takes years to develop guys that's
a pretty hard muscle
to portray a body language where if you
do say something at me i don't hear it
yeah and to boot after
three or four times they just give up
yeah they just go this guy is not gonna
react to us at all unless we let
ourselves on fire we're just gonna give
up it's so weird it's such a weird
muscle to get that confidence to let
your body language know i don't want to
hear what you got to [ __ ] say no
unless i talk to you
then you speak until that [ __ ] time
don't [ __ ] say i don't address people
much no it's really weird i wanna i
wanna i wanna do what i wanna do up
there
it's funny when you move to l.a that's
the first thing they say to you and i'll
never forget i had a dear friend
from texas
good comic you know worked hard came up
here a little too soon for his time
and uh
at that time i had a room in bray
listen every new comic needs 100 bucks
you know right so i called him up i said
what are you doing wednesday you want to
come down to bray and do the absolutely
he had bailed me out a couple times at
gigs
he went down and i'll never forget this
this had to be like
the first wednesday after christmas
he went down there he got on stage
first he did that texas stuff
i want to thank the troops
oh yeah you're in bran no california
they don't even know yeah you know
and i saw that strike and then he did
two or three jokes
he did okay he had him
but he started improvising
and when he got off that stage
two maybe three days later there was an
emergency in texas
and that was [ __ ] six or seven years
ago
like they couldn't take make the
transition
like it was unthinkable you know uh
it's such a weird
uh
beast comedy especially
the way you're doing it because you do
so many different things so everything
that you do adds to that art
like right now one thing i am good at
like i'm okay at stand up but you know
what i realize i'm really good at now
when i do it i can act my ass
like i know my lines i know where to
stand
i know how to [ __ ] block i don't say
nothing
i go prepared like i look at the room
while they're shooting something else
look at the speed they're moving
you can gauge [ __ ] and i see myself now
and i'm like wait a second next time i
do something i gotta ask for more money
because i'm [ __ ] good this is people
are [ __ ] up they're coming in here
with wrinkle shirts yeah they don't know
anything about anything you know i
always tell lee that i did a soap opera
years ago and if i hadn't had the
experience i had from the years of being
here i would have got fired the first
day that's the heart you're you're soap
opera no hardest thing right you got to
learn a million lines
no they got teleprompt decisions oh
really but you it's like nobody talks to
you right you do where's my line we'll
just show you one right what's the name
of the show
who's lying today isn't it where's your
line who's ha whose line isn't anyway
you get there you you show your
identification they tell you where to
park
you walk out there's an a.d who comes up
to you how you doing mr proops hi
you're in the locker room three beats
and they walk you in also another guy
greg brooks is saying right you know i
said have a good day bye-bye and also
another guy comes and gets you and they
walk you to your thing and they go
you're hungry mr proops and you go yeah
what's on the menu today
um and there's a ham and egg sandwich
i'm taking you take the sandwich and all
sudden you lock the door you put your
bag down
hi hi wardrobe we're gonna we're gonna
hang this here for you but go ahead take
your time eat breakfast
whatever we're not shooting yet and they
close the door and you get the phone
you're about to call your wife
hi hair and makeup
don't forget eat your breakfast we'll
come get you okay you close the door you
know and that but they're involved
okay right there you had involvement
they all come [ __ ] back and they
dress you and they look at your shirt
and they they say okay you're seeing 16a
you're gonna block and then you're gonna
put wardrobe on let's do it this way and
that's all you're shooting today okay
that's it
at least you had guidance
when you do a soap opera the time i
didn't talk at the general hospital
called time eight o'clock
and what was weird was when i got it my
agent called and then somebody called me
from there and they're like listen
you're coming at eight you're out of
there by 11 o'clock i'm like
this person's never shot television
right
like that's what i said to myself i'm
like
i got two scenes and i'm gonna be out of
there by 11 and there's three there was
like 16 in front of me yeah of course
i'm like good luck
i'll be out of there by 11 honey i'm not
going to see you like 10 o'clock dog i'm
gonna get banked today
really
i walked in there at 8 o'clock bro and
that was it says
onset 8 14 right by 8 14 [ __ ]
rehearsed for one minute it was by the
clock right now i mean greg brooks
you looked at your sheet and the time it
said you're going to be on set
at 10 38 and your first [ __ ] line is
going to be at 10 41 right you bet your
ass that computer was moving with or
without you and by the time this scene
popped up there's a teleprompter in your
[ __ ] room there's two teleprompters
you you check in and and they give you a
slip and they go to room 38 and that's
it that's the last human contact
right that's a scary situation
yeah like 38 what's 38 38. you don't
know what 38 is 38 and you walk to 38
and there's clothes in there hanging up
there's no [ __ ] woman in there
waiting for you right there's clothes
hanging up
and there's a script and there's a
contract and you fill it out and it
tells you uh where people who are in the
scenes
22 to 28 come out to the thing in five
minutes you go out there people shake
your hand hi hawaii nice to have you on
the set you're playing who's in bad okay
let's rehearse it boom boom boom boom
okay thank you
you go you get your egg sandwich you eat
it you drink your little cranberry juice
you put your little [ __ ] suit on and
you watch that teleprompter in your room
there's a teleprompter what's going on
on stage and there's a teleprompter the
scenes and when they want you out there
and it's no [ __ ] nobody comes in that
room really nice
nothing jesus christ greg proof it's
intimidating as [ __ ] right and all of a
sudden it goes scene 48 let's say you're
in scene 51
they'll go 51 come to the stage
that quick greg proof you walk onto the
stage that all sudden somebody comes out
does final [ __ ] touches okay blah
blah blah they wipe your shoes
whatever's going to be in the scene
scene 51 places scene 51
uh scene one take one action boom boom
boom greg proof snow joe diaz blah blah
blah blah okay [ __ ] you no [ __ ] you if
you [ __ ] up on your line it's not start
the scene over no
pick it up from right there say it again
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you action cut thank you
we'll see you back here for 54. that's
alpha don't even leave just go to the
corner right
it's cameras everywhere and a wall wow
and all of a sudden you walk off and
also the other team and all of a sudden
come on back and all of a sudden ready
action papa papa
if you [ __ ] up pick it up from there
thank you have a great weekend
you look at your clock they were a
minute early dog
right
you wrapped at 11 11.
and that's how fast you went to your
room you took your clothes off you left
it there there was no thank you no there
was no have a good weekend yeah great to
have you tonight oh my god your scene
was tremendous
nobody says
dick
dick you leave there like what the [ __ ]
wow but
the only thing that bails us out
is our
comedy experience
that's what really at the end i always
thought bailed me out of those
situations i don't know why
i don't know if i'm just people you have
the confidence to be yourself too and
stand there and be something
and make a decision you got to make a
decision he's a seasoned actress i'm an
[ __ ] yeah i took six weeks of classes
at eventually
two more with that guru on [ __ ]
lebron i know nothing these people went
to juilliard right right and they were
in programs and they did four years of
college shakespeare and all of a sudden
that walks in
and these like the people i saw on the
set of uh
whatever i had seen before the guy that
played the head mobster i grew up on
that guy on something
this guy just didn't wasn't know johnny
come late
i think he's still on there
you follow me lee you got to cover every
[ __ ] base i feel you right you're 28
years old if you didn't learn anything
from this podcast tonight my man great
proofs cover every base he plays chess
he sings
he dances he does stand up he's a writer
he's a dad he's a husband
what the [ __ ] you gonna do with your
life lee you gotta go yeah do your thing
happy holidays i'm just gonna read two
ads anything you need to promote uh
whatever you want podcast great smartest
man in the world on itunes or
gregproops.com and all my gigs are on
there too and uh come and join us in our
fine adventures around the world
always a pleasure seeing you thanks for
having me just gonna run two ads i'm
getting out of here myself i got [ __ ] to
do and people to see where were we
[ __ ] we talked about tushy we
talked about uh
we spoke about uh am i getting up early
yeah whatever you want to do
so we spoke about hellotushy.com
tremendous okay now i got something for
you that you like you oh [ __ ] i almost
lit this on fire i gotta be careful
hearing [ __ ]
listen dawg i'm like you guys
i don't read a lot of magazines but i
like reading them from time to time
you know i'll pick up the hollywood
report i don't know what i'm reading
i'll pick up time i read time on uh
twitter or something like that
you know i'll read uh
rolling stone
let me tell you something my friend
that's the service called texture this
will blow
your
mind okay
thanks to pizza wall binge eating thanks
to netflix we're all binge watching but
now with texture you can start binge
reading trust me
it's about to be a thing when it comes
to magazines you know what you like and
with texas you get all the magazines you
want in one super convenient place texas
has completely
reimagined magazines
giving you the articles and stories you
really want all in one place all right
plus interactive features videos and
recommendations just for you the texture
app lets you tap into the world's most
popular magazines anytime anywhere using
your smartphone or tablet breeze through
hundreds of your favorite magazines
including back issues and pink the
articles that interest you the most
alright listen men's fitness men's
health men's journal money national
geographic new york magazine
start binge reading for free all right
sign up protection right now and gain
inside access to all the content from
the world's best publications the best
part is text is offering my listeners a
free trial right now when you go to
texture.com joey again you'll gain
immediate entry to all the top magazines
including back issues and bonus video
content start binge reading for free
right now when you go to texas.com
joey again texture.com
slash joey
my main people on it.com you know i love
you [ __ ] are all my heart
as far as supplements are concerned
listen alpha brain
hundred percent money back guarantee
new mood shroom tech me and mark while
using the shroom tech again jiu jitsu
ah listen i live and die with them the
hemp forced chocolate protein and the
acai protein i live it down with the
mc40 the the oil the coconut oil
tremendous in your coffee in the morning
listen i don't know you want me to blow
smoke up your ass and go to the website
and read word for word you're more
intelligent than that go to honor.com
right now
go to go to honor.com look at the
supplement page i can't get you any help
on the weights and the metal bats but as
far as supplements i'll get you 10
percent off because that's how i [ __ ]
wrote [ __ ] all right go to honda.com
and press in church boom c-h-u-r-c-h
and get ten percent off and don't forget
next thursday night write it down right
now ceso tv
go there right now
and uh put in codename joey
and get two months for free and you get
to watch the special next thursday do me
that favor you know i got your back get
my back have a great weekend we'll talk
to you next monday morning all right
stay black and beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
check it out
oh
is
johnny
oh
[Music]
you